if you are under metabolic constraints
meaning you don't have the energy right
that all the energy in the world you
have to be efficient that immediately
forces you to start telling stories
about coarse grained agents that do
things right you don't have the energy
to like laplace's demon you know
calculate every every possible uh State
that's going to happen you have to you
have to coarse grain and you have to say
that is the kind of creature that does
things either things that I avoid or
things that I will go towards that's a
mate or food or whatever it's going to
be and so right at the base of uh simple
very simple organisms starting to make
models of Agents doing things that is
the origin of uh models of of Free Will
basically right because you see the
world around you as having agency and
then you turn that on yourself and you
say wait I have agency too I can I do
things right and and then you make
decisions about what you're going to do
so all of this one one model is to view
all of those kinds of things as
being driven by that early need to
determine what you are and to do so and
to then take actions in the most
energetically efficient space possible
right so free will emerges when you try
to simplify tell a nice narrative about
your environment I think that's very
possible yeah do you think Free Will is
an illusion
so so you're kind of implying that it's
a useful hack
well I'll say two things the first thing
is I think I think it's very plausible
to say that any organism that's self or
any agent that's self whether it's
biological or not any agent that's
self-constructs under energy constraints
is going to believe in free will but
we'll get to whether it has free will
momentarily but but I think but I think
what what it definitely drives is a view
of yourself and the outside world as an
agential view I think that's inescapable
so that's true for even primitive
organisms I think so I think this now
now they don't have now obviously you
have to scale down right so so so so
they don't have for the kinds of complex
metacognition that we have so they can
do long-term planning and thinking about
Free Will and so and so on but but the
sense of agency is really useful to
accomplish a tasks simple or complicated
that's right in in all kinds of spaces
not just in in obvious three-dimensional
space I mean we're very good that the
thing is
humans are very good at detecting agency
of like medium-sized objects moving at
medium speeds in the three-dimensional
world right we see a bowling ball and we
see a mouse and we immediately know what
the difference is right and how we're
gonna mostly things you can eat or get
eaten by yeah yeah that's our that's our
training set right from the time you're
little your training set is visual data
on on this this like little chunk of
your experience but imagine if imagine
if uh from the time that we were born we
had innate senses of your blood
chemistry if you could feel your blood
chemistry the way you can see right you
had a high bandwidth connection and you
could feel your blood chemistry and you
could see you could sense all the things
that your organs were doing so your
pancreas your liver all the things if if
we had that you we would be very good at
detecting intelligence and physiological
space we would know the level of
intelligence that our various organs
were deploying to deal with things that
were coming to anticipate the stimuli to
you know but but we're just terrible at
that we don't in fact in fact people
don't even you know you talk about
intelligence of these other spaces and a
lot of people think that's just crazy
because because all all we're all we
know is motion